you know I was so I was so influenced by
the films of the 70s in the 60s and 70s
you know the great filmmakers like
antonioni and Fellini and but well and
all these and we just don't have those
films anymore and with where it films
that asked a lot of questions where you
left feeling emotionally satisfied but
you didn't have all the answers today we
like to have everything underlined in
bold and caps and then repeated three or
four times in the film thief so people
understand it and so I wanted make one
of those films where you have to go out
you have to watch the film with your
friends and go out on the sidewalk
afterwards the same what the hell was
that about and so he says there was this
and this is the argue about it until you
want have an emotional reaction then
figure it out with your friends I guess
everything has been a surprise because
it was about five years ago that I
relentlessly I only suggested Pali Coast
movies just because I'm Jewish and I
thought I could play one of the roles
just try to find a character for myself
and just act but Paul was very
encouraging to try to find what I want
to write about or discuss and that
process really encouraged me to ask
really serious questions because he
wouldn't just stop and asking um okay
tell me about this relationship you
would ask why does that bother you even
in somebody else's relationship why does
that bother you because it's all a
projection and reflects what you don't
like about yourself if there was
something that I was judging about other
people so every time the process became
more and more of a reality it was a
surprise to me like we're we're actually
gonna make this movie oh it's there's a
script I'm gonna be it was I'm in the
Academy Award place here with real
members that and I'm from hyphen o this
everything was a surprising and every
day working with an incredible group of
talent and then there was another
incredible process for me was to
discover and create a character
and that took a while and I discovered a
lot of things about being a gypsy being
a rejected character and a country that
women are very much adored but as a
gypsy you're treated really like dirt
and to get to that specificity and
rejection took a certain effort and and
they were all very supportive I mean
scared but i would go to that extent but
very supportive to to find those nuances
and how that felt here I wanted to may
start with the title a third person I
love the idea that that Liam's character
journaled in the third person and they
talked up with themselves in the third
person to think he was distancing
himself from his own feelings even in
his journal and exploring that and that
that level of denial that a man like him
could have that he's that you know he is
trying to write and I experiences trying
to write about these characters and the
characters keep trying to take you
somewhere else and you keep saying kid
get back here until the characters in
his case finally literally physically
take him to to what you've been trying
to deny this entire time this is
terrible guilt he's been feeling that
he's trying to work out through the
characters and you know to trying to
find the way that the characters kept
repeating themselves we're from 112
story to the next one Maya dialogue
which we could come up here and there
and it's really interesting because it's
there's so many of those repeated lines
in the movie but people don't notice
them because the actors are so good that
they each give them their own like all
the girls say watch me at some point or
other there's there's all the various
other lines that are just repeated all
the way through in order to give you a
hint at what's going on because I like
playing with genres i did with in the
valley of ella i was going to say okay
this is a murder mystery relax it's a
murder history is going to follow the
conventions of murder mysteries this
Tommy Lee Jones character is going to
get to the truth he's going to fight
everybody else he's going to be right in
the end that's the conventions of murder
mysteries and get to act two and go oh I
was kidding it's not a murder mystery
it's a moral mystery and so suddenly
that people just rush up and hand him
the the answers which he of course
rejects so here I wanted to say okay
relax it's just three love stories but
then very quickly into this piece things
start happening that cannot physically
happen and so many people is releasing
just don't notice it we were trying so
obvious which we thought was so obvious
but just people I mean your bet you
didn't see a lot of these things because
you don't have see it two or three times
just to notice that even though we
thought it was obvious in the editing
for example in the when you're in Bar
americano adrius an old man walks in the
door Adrienne's character looks out the
door a Mercedes passes with a woman in
the back car in the back of the seat
that's Olivia Wilde and it's in the next
thing you see is her putting on her and
putting on her makeup game dress and
she's in Paris they are then then
they're walking down the street Liam and
and Olivia walking on the street the
first thing he's done he's standing at a
gallery he's looking at a painting you
know people oh and there's a name on the
bottom of whose that is and people walk
on and almost no one noticed that's that
painting shows that beginning Rick
slough that's Rick's painting and so I
want to say this is how he's getting the
ideas to rewrite not only the stories
but his life you know and tilted till
until finally something happens that
just you cannot you know very funny some
critics said oh it's a terrible movie
they it was a good movie with you have
to have to somehow fix this the
continuity in this because because Mila
Kunis is character was the guy is subtly
in once the country and then she's in
the next like as if we didn't notice and
that's what purposely why I put this
thing in 3 completely different cities
there's no way and for a while when we
were trying to figure out how to shoot
this many people came to us and we can
finance this to be shooter on one city
can you rewrite them all for one city
and I want yeah but then people might
get confused in a bad way I want you to
be confused in a good way is if you're
in the same city they might actually be
able to intersect I want to make a story
which it's impossible for the intersect
and yet you figure out what's going on